un univers de poésie de beauté et un
univers d'humour c'est en ces termes
très élogieux que jack lang a parlé du
parc astérix un parc est inauguré ce
matin à plailly dans l'oise alors dans
la grande concurrence des parcs
d'attraction il faudra désormais compter
avec le petit guerrier gaulois
je crois que ça peut être un lieu idéal
de rencontre entre l'histoire la culture
l'environnement le jeu la découverte et
puis le plaisir d'être ensemble
je pense que l'initiative prise ici pour
la série 7 est très encourageante et et
réchauffe le coeur je me dire que des
français les équipes françaises ont
conçu cet équipement et lille ont fait
avec beaucoup de goût d'exigence et
d'ambition vous pensez ça peut être un
atout pour une région très l'asu
formidable d'ailleurs d'ores et déjà
voulez vous l'observez la réalisation
elle-même a été créatrice d'emplois
d'activité de revenus source de
redéploiement d'activités et j'en suis
convaincu la venue d'un immense public
apportera en visiteurs des revenus à
cette région et à l'ensemble de la
région parisienne